John let me start with you so this means
uber will be regulated on a country by
country and even a city by city basis
what does that mean for it well the the
reason that the ruber took the challenge
was because it wanted it the EU wide
regulatory regime would be slightly more
favorable to it and if it were
determined to be a digital services
provider and information services
provider then it would it would have
been regulated at the EU level and if
you like further obstacles would be
potentially in its way to restrictions
but being regarded as a transportation
services provider its regulated at the
member state level because that's a
derogated area what is that going to
mean in terms of hoover's costs can we
is it possible to put a number on it it
probably is like hah i won't venture to
try to put a number now I've seen some
commentators saying that if the drivers
are regarded as workers then they'll no
longer have self-employed status and
then potentially v80 if the applicable
so I've seen some comments and along
those lines which would be quite
significant that would be 20% on the on
the cost of goodness well James let me
bring you at this point so 20% or
lubbers costs presumably that is all
going to get passed on to the poor old
customer at the end of the day well it
may or it may not
I mean at the moment uber is enjoying a
benefit of under paying drivers below
the minimum wage a lot of drivers have
been propped up by the welfare system
and so there is no such thing as a free
ride but I think what we're seeing with
the ruling here today is that ubers
business model fundamentally is in
tatters now and what we're seeing is
that failure in regulation in the United
Kingdom in terms of employment law in
terms of taxation law in terms of
transportation law and every time we go
to court to challenge the regulation
that we've had our regulation comes up
short the tailor review hasn't answered
this question either so when we Matthew
Taylor from the RSA that's right his
review of modern employment practices
for the government for the cake economy
when we went to tribunal against uber
uber argued that it is the agent of the
and that we are the principles in the
business now our judge in the tribunal
over a year ago said this was pure
fiction and the European Court of
Justice has agreed today what that
knocks the knock-on effect of that is
that uber has previously sort of argued
that while the driver is responsible for
v80 and since we are all below the v18
threshold of 85,000 pounds and
low-income then nobody pays v80 now all
of a sudden uber could have to pay that
v80 and the other thing is is its
initial public offering
uber went to the SEC in October and
argued this agency principle argument
that it is merely an agent it is not a
transportation provider the SEC accepted
that but since then we've had an
employee Airy Appeals Tribunal has ruled
against that and so has the European
Court of Justice
and finally the HMRC went before the
Public Accounts Committee last month and
they said that they were looking at two
important cases to determine how they
would go forward on taxation maneuver
and one was our case which we
subsequently won and the second was this
case which has now come in favor of
against uber so in the new year maybe in
2018 HMRC will take a run at uber okay
well John the European Court of Justice
can often be quite vague in some of its
rulings it's been very very precise here
hasn't it yes I mean it was it was a
relatively short judgement for the
European Court but yeah I mean the it
was it was the choice really between is
it a digital service or is it a
transportation service I think they
probably had some sympathy with uber I
mean they had to obviously consider the
position but they they have a doctrine
of the center of gravity and once they
looked at is this more an information
society services sphere or is this more
a transportation sphere I suppose it was
irresistible
they said you know in reality it's it's
a transportation service so that's where
you know the where we have to land and
that's where the regulatory implications
will follow this is actually quite
pertinent though to the brexit debate
isn't it because I mean this highlights
how difficult it is to get a single
market in vast parts of the services
sector
problem for the UK potentially because
we're a services economy yeah I think so
I mean well in this in this particular
case and they've decided that actually
transportation is an area that's that's
within the the influence of member
states so I suppose to that extent they
won't wouldn't necessarily be a brexit
implication of this but but I think it's
it's that's right it's you know it's
always a important topic all right James
very briefly what does this mean for
other companies operating in the gig
economy do you think this is going to
have an impact elsewhere companies like
delivery well the common factor here is
that a lot of these companies reinvented
themselves they position themselves as
digitized firms in the cloud with no
real infrastructure responsibilities on
the ground but of course somebody has to
get on the bike and deliver your food
somebody has to drive you from A to B in
the car and with that comes
responsibilities whether it's employment
law or taxation and so on so I think
that's the big lesson here we're that's
what we've went to Tribunal to prove
that we're workers that were entitled to
the minimum wage all right James Frey
John Doherty gonna leave it there thanks
for joining human